künstliche intelligenz hat einen mega
durchbruch geschafft sie könnte jetzt
zum lebensretter für unzählige menschen
werden denn sie hat unter tausenden von
stoffen ein extrem wirksames
antibiotikum entdeckt das ist nach
langer zeit mal wieder ein echter
fortschritt in dem bereich den
pharmaunternehmen zum teil schon
aufgegeben haben weil ihre mittel viel
zu schnell und wirksam geworden sind
aber hat das chianti kündigung überhaupt
eine chance gegen die immer schnelleren
resistenz der bakterien und seid
gespannt am freitag ändert sich hier
etwas ab clixoom was erfahre am ende des
videos nicht um science-fiction hier
gibt's täglich spannendes sein ziel ist
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen klicks und
gibt es jetzt auch als podcast übrigens
und zwar für unterwegs der link zur
spotify und apple podcasts bis unten in
der video beschreibung antibiotika
gehören zu den größten errungenschaften
der medizin oder fangen wir anders an
künstliche intelligenz ki gehört zu den
größten errungenschaften der menschheit
denn immer öfter erzählt sie
bahnbrechende erfolge zuletzt alpha
folgt ein programm das zehnmal besser
war als alles vorher und zwar darin
proteine richtig zu falten
eine herkulesaufgabe und die hat sie von
einem auf den anderen tag viel besser
gelöst als alle anderen programme und by
the way menschen oder normale
computerprogramme können das gar nicht
und jetzt soll alpha fold bei der
entwicklung eines medikaments gegen
cupid 19 helfen es hat schon sechs
proteine gefaltet die wirken könnten
alpha fold wird übrigens von deep meint
entwickelt der tochter von google in
london und nur um mal die bedeutung von
ki ins rechte licht zu rücken
sie wird die welt verändern und hat es
jetzt getan und ein antibiotikum
entdeckt einen meilenstein der
medikamente gegen bakterielle
infektionen haben mittlerweile ein
echtes problem viele von ihnen wirken
einfach nicht mehr weil bakterien
zunehmend resistenzen entwickeln und das
hat schreckliche folgen jedes jahr
sterben hunderttausende menschen an
resistenten erregern die lage hat sich
inzwischen so zugespitzt dass die
weltgesundheitsorganisation kurz whu die
antibiotika resistenten schon als größte
und dringendste globale
gesundheitsgefahr benannt hat
im letzten jahr hat sie einen globalen
plan gegen multiresistente erreger
aufgestellt der zielt darauf ab dass die
medikamente die nicht mehr wirken
sparsamer eingesetzt werden und neue
antibiotika entwickelt werden die
forschung an diesen mitteln ist aber
sehr mühsam und aufwendig und für viele
pharmakonzerne einfach nicht mehr
lukrativ denn nachdem jahrelang in die
entwicklung neuer stoffe investiert
wurde können die mittel schon schnell
wieder unwirksam werden teilweise
entwickeln sich die resistenzen sogar so
schnell dass die antibiotika schon nicht
mehr wirken wenn sie gerade auf den
markt gekommen sind sie werden nicht
lange genug eingenommen und damit machen
sich erkrankte zu brutstätten für
resistente keime und sie werden in der
landwirtschaft als standard eingesetzt
bei der tierzucht und das ist auch eine
brutstätte und im indischen hyderabad wo
große mengen antibiotika für den
weltmarkt produziert werden gelangen
erhebliche mengen der antibiotika ins
abwasser indien gilt damit inzwischen
als die brutstätte für multiresistente
keime weltweit und diese ja fast
aussichtslose situation ist sicherlich
einer der gründe weshalb ist in den
letzten zehn jahren kaum fortschritte in
diesem bereich gab doch eine neue studie
könnt ihr jetzt für eine überraschende
wendung sorgen forschende von
massachusetts institute of technology
haben ein neues antibiotikum entdeckt
das wirklich vielversprechend aussieht
allerdings haben sie das nicht alleine
geschafft das team um den
wissenschaftler james collins hatte
dabei hilfe von künstlicher intelligenz
die forscher haben einen algorithmus
trainiert sie stellten im daten zur
verfügung die informationen über die
atomare struktur und den aufbau von
2.500 molekülen beinhalten davonkommen
1700 aus einer datenbank der
amerikanischen lebensmittelbehörde fti
in der bekannte wirkstoffe enthalten
sind außerdem sagen die daten aus wie
gut die moleküle das wachstum von
escherichia coli bakterien auch bekannt
als e coli ausbremsen können mit diesen
daten sollte der algorithmus dann lernen
bakterien tötenden stoffe zu erkennen
die den bekannten antibiotika möglichst
unähnlich sind nach diesem training
wurde die ki auf 6.000 substanzen aus
einer anderen großen stoff datenbank
losgelassen mit erfolg die ki bestätigte
eine starke antibiotische wirkung beim
stoff harley ziehen
ein weiterer algorithmus ermittelten das
menschliche zellen dieses molekül gut
vertragen der stoff wurde ursprünglich
als diabetes-medikament getestet habe
aber nie auf den markt nach der ki
entdeckung wurde seine wirksamkeit gegen
dutzende bakterienstämme getestet und er
schlug tatsächlich bei allen
untersuchten spezies an darunter sogar
tuberkulose erregern die ganz oben auf
der liste stehen für die dringend neue
antibiotika gebraucht werden nur gegen
einen schwer behandelbaren lungen kam
konnte das mittel nichts ausrichten
anschließend gestand das antibiotikum
auch die tests in lebenden organismus
und zeigte seine wirksamkeit die kommt
vermutlich durch die überraschende
wirkung des stoffs den energiemangel den
er bei bakterien erzeugt er schränkt
ihre fähigkeit einen einen
elektrochemischen gradienten in der
zellmembran aufrecht zu erhalten also
das auf einer seite mehr teilchen in
einer bestimmten art vorhanden sind als
auf der anderen seite ohne den können
sie kein atp adenosintriphosphat
herstellen und das ist ein wichtiger
energieträger fehlt er sterben die
bakterien ab alle bisherigen ergebnisse
geben wirklich hoffnung dass das mittel
ein neuer durchbruch sein könnte
es soll jetzt weiter untersucht werden
denn es müssen erst nebenwirkungen
ausgeschlossen werden bevor es beim
menschen eingesetzt werden kann aber
kann das antibiotikum bis dahin nicht
schon wieder unwirksam sein
auch hier gibt es richtig gute
nachrichten die forschenden halten das
für unwahrscheinlich denn der
wirkmechanismus ist sehr stark
um sich vor dem angriff auf die
zellmembran zu schützen würden
mutationen an einer oder ein paar
stellen nicht ausreichen stattdessen
werden schon sehr komplexe mutationen
nötig bei tests mit e.coli bakterien gab
es selbst nach über dreißig tagen noch
keine resistenzen zum vergleich
entwickeln bakterien bei einem bekannten
antibiotikum diese schon innerhalb von
einem bis drei tagen das risiko für
resistenzen gegen das mittel ist also
eher gering das ist ein wahnsinnserfolg
für die ki und für das forschungsteam
und damit noch nicht genug mit ihrer
hilfe wurden noch acht weitere
vielversprechende wirkstoffe entdeckt
und ki könnte in zukunft die forschung
an antibiotika endlich wieder schneller
und günstiger machen und sie erheblich
vorantreiben an wirklich bahnbrechende
erfolg für die medizin und eben nicht
nur das antibiotikum sondern eben
insbesondere auch der weg ist zu
entdecken
wir stehen vielleicht wirklich vor der
technologischen singularität also dazu
demnächst ein extra video schon mit
diesem video gehen wir schon ein wenig
in die richtung von klicks um ihn zu
kommt wir werden klick so nämlich
verändern und zwar grundlegend wie in
diesem video wollen wir
gesamtzusammenhänge zeigen es wird
tiefer auf den themen angegangen und wir
zeigen die positiven und auch negativen
perspektiven auf das bedeutet dass es
hier nicht mehr nur die zuweilen kurzen
info häppchen zu verschiedenen themen
geben wird keine news mehr sondern mehr
inhalt in den videos und deswegen auch
nicht mehr täglich sondern dreimal die
woche die zeit ändert sich und auch wir
ändern uns denn im bus von täglichen
nachrichten häppchen übersieht man
manchmal das große ganze und darauf
wollen wir jetzt den fokus legen mit
neuem design vertiefen infos und mehr
kontext seid also gespannt auf freitag
schreibt gerne in den kommentaren was
ihr davon haltet und beteiligt euch auch
an der umfrage unter dem community tab
und hier das video zur bahnbrechenden
entwicklung von alpha folgt durchbruch
bei ki gibt meint revolutioniert die
medizin anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran manches ändert sich
halt nie